aujourd'hui on va parler de ballon mais
de ballons qu'on éclate
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous ne le savez peut-être pas mais un
ballon peut éclater de deux façons
différentes
si on gonfle modérément puis qu'on
lepers on va se retrouver avec deux
fragments différents deux morceaux si on
gonfle à bloc jusqu'à ce qu'il éclate on
va se retrouver avec plein de petits
morceaux
des chercheurs du laboratoire de
physique statistique de paris se sont
intéressés à ce phénomène
pour cela ils ont utilisé un dispositif
dédié avec une caméra ultra rapide avec
une caméra ultrarapide et un système
pour gonfler des feuilles de latex ils
se sont rendu compte que plus la surface
est tendu plus la fissure va se déplacer
rapidement à la surface du ballon et
c'est justement cette vitesse de
déplacement qui va déterminer la forme
de la fissure une fois que la fissure
atteint une vitesse limite elle se
sépare en deux nouvelles fissures et
c'est ce qui aboutit au réseau de
fissures qu'on voit sur les images
cette vitesse limite les chercheurs ont
mesuré ses 570 mètres par seconde
plus de 2000 kilomètres heure cette
recherche paraît donc un peu loufoque
mais en fait elle est très sérieuse
elle permet de mieux comprendre la
fragmentation des matériaux ce cas des
applications dans des domaines très
variés comme l'aéronautique ou le génie
civil
enfin tout ce qui est science des
matériaux en fête est donc bien au delà
de la fragmentation du latex
même si une fissure dans la tex ça peut
avoir des conséquences non négligeables
et abonnez vous